Alright, it is time for hatred mail. This
week's hatred mail. Actually, there's something
really important in this week's hatred mail
I want to talk about. Um, but before we get
to that quick reminder about what hatred mail
is,
[inaudible]
the right of the people to keep and bear hates
shall not be in [inaudible]. Hey, it [inaudible]
written by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom.
All right, let's get right into this week's
Patriot mail and I'll play it. And then there's
going to be, I, I'm concerned about something
beyond just, Oh, this is a hatred and they
say horrible things. Let's take a listen to
it.
David is a Warren or butter gay shill. You've
lied at least six times in this video. You've
died. In fact, your intelligence suggests
that you are a very conniving propagandas
to shill a shill who is very much aware of
what the real truth is in off it. Aware for
sure. LMF AEO. How though are you calling
Trump? Anti semantic? He literally moved the
embassy to Israel.
So listen, uh, okay. It's a homophobic thing
about Pete booted. Judge Pete. Boudin judge
is a gay man. Your, you know, you're a Buddha
gay shill or whatever. Number one, I don't
support people who to judge. When I pointed
out that he was soaring in the polls, nearly
tripling his support over the last few months,
I actually said Anne and I don't support him
now, I don't know the political leanings of
this hatred, but I've seen more homophobic
sort of comments about Pete Buddha judge from
the left then I'm comfortable with and you
know, I don't support him. I think he's a
centrist, but it wouldn't even occur to me
to start nicknaming P booted judge with anything
that sort of jokes about or ridicules the
fact that he's a gay man. Um, I get that.
We're going to see that from the right because
the right is a homophobic in, in, in, in the
policy that they've advocated for.
You know, they don't want gay marriage to
be legal. They often want it to be illegal
to fire someone for their real or perceived
sexual orientation. We know about all that
stuff. We on the left should simply, if we
don't like Buddha judge, we should say here's
his policy and here's why I don't like it.
But I've seen, um, you know, too many people,
uh, on Twitter and in different places do
sort of coined nicknames for Pete, Buddha
judge that sometimes more overtly, sometimes
less overtly are making fun of the fact that
he's a gay man. Come on guys. I thought that
we had moved past that I wish that we could.
Um, and the stuff from the left, just say
you don't like his policy. Say you don't like
him as an individual, that's actually fine
too. It's okay not to like someone because
they just rub you the wrong way and you say,
I'm supporting someone else that I find more
endearing or whatever the case.
But the homophobic nicknames for people who
to judge are, um, uh, I expect it from the
right. I'm disheartened when I see it from
the left. Let's just cut it out. Remember
that you can use the coupon code. Hey, treat
40 H a T R I O T for zero to save 40% off
of the membership of your choice@joinpacman.com